हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है? जल्दी से बताइए।
तो बिल्कुल क्लियर सुनाई दे रही है साफसाफ
आई एम ऑडिबल लाउड एंड क्लियर एवरीवन
ओके मैं फाइन मैं अच्छा हूं आप लोग बताइए
कैसे हो
सब लोग अच्छे हो आप लोग
जी हर हर महादेव
हाय हेलो एवरीवन
तो देखते हैं थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं एक
मिनट के लिए कि कितने स्टूडेंट्स आएंगे
हमारी क्लास में क्योंकि ये टॉपिक नया है
और यूनिक टॉपिक है और जैसा आपको पता है कि
हमने प्रॉमिस किया था डीएचई की सीरीज कोई
ऐसी सीरीज नहीं है जो टाइम पास के लिए यह
वो सीरीज है जो
अनएक्सेक्टेड होगी बहुत लोगों के लिए
क्योंकि अभी तक जो कंटेंट था आपको YouTube
पे कहीं ना कहीं मिल जाता। बट अब से जो
कंटेंट आएगा YouTube पर चांसेस उसके बहुत
कम हैं। कि आप सोच ले कि बहुत कम चांस उस
कंटेंट के मिलने के। मिल भी जाएंगे तो
डिटेल्स में और पूरा डिस्क्रिप्शन के साथ
और इतनी ज्यादा क्लासेस में नहीं होगा
क्योंकि यह तो शुरुआत है और ऐसे बहुत सारे
कंटेंट है जो आने वाले हैं।
और प्रेजेंट जो बिगिनियर जो आपने सीरीज की
है जो बिगिनिंग तक अभी तक आपने 53 क्लासेस
ली हैं तो 53 क्लासेस में तो हमने अपनी
फंडामेंटल्स और बिगिनिंग जर्नी को कंप्लीट
किया है जो बिगिनियर प्लस प्लस जो मैं
वर्ड यूज़ कर रहा हूं इंटरमीडिएट तो हमने
और प्रोफेशनल लेवल तो अभी तक स्टार्ट ही
नहीं किया है। तो अगर आप लोगों का सपोर्ट
नहीं होगा तो प्रोफेशनल जो प्रोफेशनल लेवल
है कभी स्टार्ट नहीं होगा डीएचसी के लिए।
अगर आप लोगों का साथ रहेगा, ऐसी चीजें
रहेंगी तो जल्द ही आपको यह लेवल भी आपको
देखने को मिलेगा।
तो आज भी लोग एक्साइटेड नहीं है। मुझे
लगता नहीं क्योंकि आज भी वही 17 18
स्टूडेंट्स हैं। तो आप लोगों का कुछ नहीं
हो सकता। तो मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं
कि आज की क्लास में व पेन टेस्टिंग या
वॉइप सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग बोल सकते हो या
जो भी बोल सकते हो आज वो कंप्लीट नहीं हो
सकती आज सिंगल क्लास में मैं यह बता दिया
इसकी भी कई क्लासेस जाएंगी क्योंकि आपको
पता है जब सचिन सर किसी चीज को पढ़ाते हैं
तो वो सिंगल एक सिंगल क्लास में कभी खत्म
नहीं करते क्योंकि वो एक काफी डिटेल के
साथ सिनेरियो के साथ और फंडामेंटल लेवल को
लेके चलते हैं। यह सबको पता है।
तो मैं वेट कर रहा हूं कि कितने
स्टूडेंट्स ज्वाइन होंगे कितने नहीं आएंगे
और 18 ही स्टूडेंट है तो सोचो कि क्या
हालत है क्या सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई तो दे
रही होगी ना और स्ट्रीमिंग भी अच्छे से आ
रही होगी कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं होगी
नेटवर्क साइड से बताइए
मैं वेट कर रहा हूं कि कितने स्टूडेंट्स
मैं एटलीस्ट उम्मीद कर रहा था कि इस टॉपिक
के लिए तो एटलीस्ट 50 टू 60 स्टूडेंट आए
बट नोबडी इज वंटी टू कम फॉर दिस कोर्स
आल्सो एंड फॉर दिस
टॉपिक आल्सो
डीएचई की इतनी सारी क्लासेस आने वाली हैं
जो बहुत सारी क्योंकि डीएचई अपने आप में
एक सर्टिफिकेशन बनने जा रहा है और जल्दी
इस सर्टिफिकेशन का एग्जाम होगा पेड एग्जाम
होगा और आपको सर्टिफिकेट दिया जाएगा।
बिल्कुल इसका लेवल बोल सकते हो कि अबव
ईजीपीटी
और अप्रोक्स ओएससीपी वी विल ट्राई कंप्लीट
नहीं बट नियर बाय वी विल ट्राई टू कि उसको
रखें और आप लोगों को वो एग्जाम देने में
मजा आए। एक फील आए आपको कि हां मैंने कोई
एग्जाम तो दिया है। तो जितने भी कंटेंट
मैं आप लोगों को पढ़ाता हूं वो कंटेंट ऐसे
नहीं है कि आप कुछ भी कंटेंट देख पा रहे
हो क्योंकि यह कंटेंट पूरा एक उस एग्जाम
के लिए प्रिपरेशन है जो आपका जल्द ही
देखने को मिलेगा आने वाले टाइम में जो आप
तभी क्लियर कर पाओगे जब आप यह कंटेंट कर
चुके होगे।
चलिए एक काम करते हैं। फिर हम चलते हैं
अपनी स्लाइड के ऊपर। स्टूडेंट मुझे पता है
नहीं आने वाले और मेरी एक्सपेक्टेशन इतनी
ही थी क्योंकि मैं आप लोगों से एक्सपेक्ट
ना करूं तो सही रहेगा।
चलो स्लाइड पर चलते हैं हम अपने
तो आज से हम स्टार्ट करने जा रहे हैं वप
हैकिंग नहीं बोल सकते एक वर्ड
है इसलिए लोग इसको सुनना पसंद करते हैं।
इसको हम बोल सकते हैं व पेन टेस्टिंग बोल
सकते हैं या व सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग। तो व
का मतलब क्या होता है? वह सारी चीजें हम
आने वाली क्लासेस में काफी डिटेल्स में
सीखेंगे और आज मैं आपको क्या बताने वाला
हूं तो बिल्कुल ध्यान से सुनना क्योंकि आज
मैं जो चीज बताने वाला हूं वो आपकी आने
वाली क्लासेस के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट है कि मैं
आपको जो चीज बताऊंगा वो आपको पता चल जाएगा
कि आपको क्यों आज की जो सीरीज है करनी
चाहिए। क्यों नहीं करनी चाहिए वह सारी
चीजें क्योंकि एक कोर्स इंट्रोडक्शन या हम
बोल सकते हैं कि कोई सेक्शन इंट्रोडक्शन
तो होना काफी जरूरी है क्योंकि जब तक आप
सेक्शन इंट्रोडक्शन नहीं करोगे किसी चीज
के बारे में कि आज हमने यह चैप्टर शुरू
किया है। इस चैप्टर का पर्पज क्या है? इस
चैप्टर को मैं क्यों स्टार्ट करने वाला
हूं जब तक मैं यह नहीं बताऊंगा तब तक कोई
फायदा नहीं उस चीजों का।
तो नाउ
आज हम वॉइस
ओवर आईपी या बोल सकते हैं व सिक्योरिटी के
बारे में बात करने वाले हैं जो आज हम जो
बात करने वाले हैं तो मेरा एक सवाल है आप
लोगों से क्या किसी को कोई भी आईडिया है
कि यह टॉपिक हम क्यों पढ़ रहे हैं? किसी
को कोई भी आईडिया है कि यह टॉपिक हम पढ़
क्यों रहे हैं?
किसी को भी कोई आईडिया हो चैट में बता
सकता है कि उसको कोई भी आईडिया कि यह
टॉपिक हम पढ़ क्यों रहे हैं? किस पर्पस से
पढ़ रहे हैं?
क्योंकि यह कोई रैंडम टॉपिक नहीं है। मैं
आपको बता देता हूं अपनी तरफ से क्योंकि इस
टॉपिक का डायरेक्ट रिलेशन हम बोल सकते हैं
आपके रियल नेटवर्क से है। या हम बोले कि
आपकी जो एंटरप्राइज होती है, एंटरप्राइज
के अंदर जो कॉलिंग सिस्टम होता है या उनसे
रिलेटेड जो सिक्योरिटी अटैक्स होते हैं
डायरेक्ट उससे संबंध है। तो
हम क्यों पढ़ रहे हैं?
किसी ने आंसर किया है। फॉरेंसिक में यूज़
होती है। ट्रैकिंग वॉइप कॉल इन फॉरेंसिक
मोबाइल टेक्नोलॉजी में यूज़ होता है। और
कोई
तो मैं फिर से आपको बता देता हूं। मेरा जो
सवाल है कि मैं जो आपसे पूछ रहा हूं कि वप
इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है या मैं आपको बोलूं कि
वप इतना स्पेशल क्यों है? क्योंकि देखो आज
के टाइम में अब मैं 2025 की बोलूं या 2026
की बात करूं तो टेक्नोलॉजी की कोई भी कमी
नहीं है। फिर भी स्पेसिफिकली हम बात करें
कि व जो वप है उसी के ऊपर फोकस क्यों किया
जा रहा है?
उसी के ऊपर ही फोकस क्यों किया जा रहा है?
ऐसी क्या चीज है इसके अंदर जो आपका जो व
है वह ट्रेडिशनल फोन सिस्टम से अलग बनाती
है? यह सारे मैं सवाल आप लोगों से आप
सवालों को आंसर दीजिए तभी हम इस पे कर
पाएंगे।
के लगभग सभी स्टूडेंट्स के आंसर सही हैं।
तो
एक और सवाल है मेरा फिर मैं आपसे पूछना
चाहूंगा कि जब अगर आप क्या कर रहे हो कि
आपका जो वॉइप कॉल है और जो आपका जो नॉर्मल
ट्रेडिशनल फोन कॉल है अगर उसको मैं आपको
बोल दूं आप कंपेयर करो तो इनमें से कौन सा
बेटर है? वॉइस कॉल बेटर है या फिर सर्किट
वि टेलीफोन कॉल्स बेटर है। यह जो जो
सर्किट वि टेलीफोन कॉल बेटर है या फिर
आपका जो वॉइस कॉल है इनमें से कौन सा बेटर
है? मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि सर्किस
स्विच टेलीफोन क्या होता है? जो सर्किट
स्विट टेलीफोन नेटवर्क है उसका मतलब है जो
आप रेगुलर लेडलाइन यूज़ करते हो जो रेगुलर
लेडलाइन आपने देखी होंगी। अगर मैं इंडिया
में बात करूं तो जो BSNL की लाइंस होती
हैं जो आपको इस फोटो में दिखाई दे रहा है
कि या किसी भी अगर आप गवर्नमेंट ऑफिस में
काम करते हो या कहीं पर भी आप ऑफिससेस में
आपने काम किया होगा वहां पर एक लेडन
टेलीफोन होता था या अभी भी होता है यूज़
किया जाता है वो आपने देखा होगा वो क्या
करता है कि एक डेडिकेटेड लाइन का यूज़ करता
है जो क्या करता है वो आपके एक डेडिकेटेड
लाइन का यूज़ करता है या एक डेडिकेटेड
सर्किट का यूज़ करता है उस कनेक्शन को
बनाने के लिए तो जिसको हम क्या बोल सकते
हैं आपका ट्रेडिशनल फोन कॉल बोल सकते हैं
या जिसको हम क्या बोल सकते हैं रेगुलर फोन
कॉल जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल आप देख पा रहे
होंगे ये रहा ऐसे आपने देखी होंगी जैसे
मैं आप स्क्रीन पे बता रहा हूं कि ये देखो
ये देखा आपने हमेशा रियल लाइफ में देखे
होंगे ये ये इमेज इस तरीके से काम करते
हुए सड़क के किनारे ऐसे बहुत सा छोटा सा
बॉक्स होगा बॉक्स में बहुत सारे वायर्स
हैं और कई बार रिपेयरिंग काम होते हुए
देखा होगा आपने ये सारी चीजें देखी हैं ये
सब आपने देखा है जो मैं आपको रिप्रेजेंट
कर रहा हूं ये सब आपने देखा हुआ है। ये
देखे आपने सबने देखा ये एवरीवन
सभी ने देखा होगा।
बिल्कुल सही बात है कि
बिल्कुल पढ़ा दूंगा। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
थोड़ा टाइम दे दो मुझे। मैं बिल्कुल पढ़ा
दूंगा। बस मेरे साथ जो करवा रहा हूं मैं
वो कीजिए। आई प्रॉमिस मैं पढ़ा दूंगा।
ओके।
चलिए तो सबने देखा तो फिर मैं वही पूछ रहा
हूं कि अगर आप दोनों को कंपेयर करोगे तो
वब कोल बेटर है या सर्किट स्विच कोल बेटर
है? आप बताओ कि वब कोल बेटर है या सर्किट
स्विफ्ट कोल बेटर कौन सी बेटर है इनमें
से?
बताओ
जल्दी से बताओ कौन सी कॉल बेटर है? वॉइप
कॉल बेटर है या सर की स्वीट कॉल या जो
आपका ट्रेडिशनल लेडन कॉल बेटर है कौन सा
कॉल बेटर है बताओ?
देखो मैं आपके जो चैट्स है कंटिन्यू देख
रहा हूं। तो जल्दी से आंसर कीजिए। वॉइप
कॉल बेटर है। बिल्कुल। तो मुझे एक और चीज
बता दो। अगर वॉइप कॉल बेटर है तो क्यों
बेटर है?
वही कोल बेटर है तो क्यों बेटर है बताओ
बताओ व कोल बेटर है तो क्यों बेटर है
चैट में आंसर कर सकते हो मैं आपके चैट देख
रहा हूं फिर मैं अभी आपका आंसर करूंगा ओके
लॉन्ग रेंज ओके इंक्रिप्शन गुड एंड नो
डेडिकेटेड लाइन गुड गुड इफ सपोर्ट वीडियोस
ऑल वेल एंड चीपर गुड चीपर मोर स्केलेबल
गुड इंक्रिप्शन वेरी गुड
मतलब आप लोगों को आईडिया है कि वप होता
क्या है सबको है ना मैं कह सकता हूं कि आप
लोग तो बिल्कुल वप इज बेटर बट व्हाई पहला
रीज़न है उसका सिक्योरिटी मतलब क्या है कि
वप कॉल को आप आसानी से इंक्रिप्ट कर सकते
हो उसके लोग्स को मेंटेन कर सकते हो उसको
मॉनिटर कर सकते हो जिससे क्या होगा जिससे
जो प्रॉब्लम्स होती थी आपकी डेडलाइन के
केस में इंटरसेप्शन की प्रॉब्लम टैपिंग की
प्रॉब्लम या जो अनअथराइज्ड लिसनिंग की जो
प्रॉब्लम है उससे प्रिवेंट किया जा सकता
है और लेकिन जो वप है उसको सही तरीके से
इंप्लीमेंट किया गया तो बिल्कुल सही तरीके
से इंप्लीमेंट किया गया तो ही ओनली आप
क्या कर सकते हो कि यह सारी चीजें मेंटेन
कर सकते हो वेब के अंदर सिक्योरिटी मेंटेन
कर सकते हो दूसरा कारण क्या है? कॉस्ट
एफिशिएंसी।
जो वप कॉल है वह काफी सस्ती मानी जाती है
क्योंकि यह क्या करती है? आपके इंटरनेट का
यूज करते हैं या फिर आपके जो प्राइवेट
आईपी नेटवर्क है उसका यूज करती है कॉलिंग
के लिए। और इसके लिए उसको कोई भी
डेडिकेटेड सर्किट की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं
है। कोई भी डेडिकेटेड टेलीफ़ोनिक लाइन की
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। ना कोई हैवी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर की कॉस्ट आती है इसके
लिए। बिल्कुल। इसीलिए फॉर एग्जांपल अगर
आपको इंटरनेशनल कॉल करना है या ब्रांच टू
ब्रांच कॉल करना है या रिमोट ऑफिसिसेस के
लिए वब कॉल सबसे बेस्ट इकोनॉमिक या
इकोनॉमिकल
सपोर्ट प्रोवाइड करती है। हम बोल सकते हैं
कि एक इकोनॉमिकल ऑप्शन माना जाता है।
बेस्ट रेदर देन आपकी डेडिकेटेड लाइन बिकॉज़
उसमें कौन-कौन सी प्रॉब्लम्स हैं? उसमें
प्रॉब्लम्स हैं। उनको इंटरसेप्ट किया जा
सकता है, टैप किया जा सकता है या कोई भी
जैसे कि मैं आपको अभी स्क्रीन पे दिखाया
था। वो डिब्बे में कोई भी अगर आपके केबल
का पता है, आपके नंबर का पता है, उसको
थोड़ी बहुत टेक्नोलॉजी का ज्ञान है, उसको
पता है तो क्या कर सकता है? वो उसको टैप
कर सकता है। उधर से आपकी कॉल को सुन लेगा
बीच में आपको रिप्लाई कर देगा और आपको लग
रहा है कि कोई आपसे बात कर रहा है।
बिल्कुल आई एम राइट। ऐसा ही हो सकता है।
क्या मैं गलत बोल रहा हूं?
क्या मैं गलत बोल रहा हूं? अगर मैं गलत
बोल रहा हूं तो मुझे बताइए।
तो
हम बोले कि सो ओवरऑल वप इज मोर फ्लेक्सिबल
मोर सिक्योर इफ कॉन्फिगरर्ड करेक्टली एंड
चीपर देन ट्रेडिशनल सर्किट स्विच
टेलीफोनिक ओके तो अगर मैं एक सवाल आप
लोगों से पूछूं कि अगर आपको लॉन्ग
डिस्टेंस डिस्टेंस या इंटरनेशनल कॉल करनी
है तो आप क्या प्रेफर करोगे?
बताओ तब आप क्या प्रेफर करोगे? अगर आपको
लॉन्ग डिस्टेंस कॉल करनी है या इंटरनेशनल
कॉल करनी है तब आप क्या प्रेफर करोगे?
वाइप कॉल प्रेफर करोगे या जो ट्रेडिशनल
टेलीफोन नेटवर्क था जो सर्किट स्विच
नेटवर्क उसको प्रेफर करोगे? बताओ क्या
प्रेफर करोगे? ऑब्वियसली आप प्रेफर करोगे
वाइप। क्यों? क्योंकि अगर आपको ट्रेडिशनल
टेलीफोन सिस्टम का यूज करना पड़ जाए लॉन्ग
डिस्टेंस के लिए तो क्या होगा? एक तो
कंट्री और कंट्री के जो एक कंट्री टू
कंट्री जो डिस्टेंस है उसके लिए आपको
सेपरेट एक्सपेंसेस प्लान लेने पड़ेंगे या
उनके लिए पेमेंट करनी पड़ेगी या फिर दूसरा
रास्ता क्या होगा कि उसकी पूरी की पूरी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को खुद से डेवलप करना
पड़ेगा जो काफी कॉस्टली है। लेकिन वॉइप
कॉल में क्या होता है? वही कॉल बहुत बेटर
ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड करता है। इंटरनेट के थ्रू
कॉल होती है। उसमें इंटरनेशनल चार्जेस का
कोई झंझट ही नहीं है। अलग से कोई चार्ज
लगता ही नहीं है। और आज के मॉडर्न वर्ल्ड
में अगर बात करें हम जो वप कॉल है वो काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है। उसका सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ किया
जाता है। चाहे वो कोई भी बिजनेस ऑपरेशंस
हो, चाहे आपकी मीटिंग्स हैं, आपके कस्टमर
कॉल्स हैं, आपके कस्टमर सपोर्ट की कॉल है,
आपके कॉन्फ्रेंसेस हैं, सब में वो कॉल का
यूज किया जाता है। इवन आपका जो पर्सनल
कम्युनिकेशंस हैं, आपका जो WhatsApp है,
आपके Gmaate है, आपके Zoom लिंक्स हैं, सब
जगह व का यूज़ किया जाता है। तो सोचो कि वप
हमारे लिए समझना क्यों जरूरी है? क्यों हम
वप को समझने वाले हैं। व्हाई इट इज़ सो
इंपॉर्टेंट? बिकॉज़ इसकी सिक्योरिटी भी
उतनी ही इंपॉर्टेंट है जितना इसको समझना
जरूरी है। क्योंकि व आपके लिए बहुत
क्रिटिकल है। आप डेली बेसिस पे यूज़ कर रहे
हो वप को। कौन यहां पर ऐसा जो WhatsApp
यूज़ नहीं कर WhatsApp पे वीडियो कॉल वॉइस
कॉल यूज़ नहीं कर रहा या कौन Google मीट या
ZM लिंक का यूज़ नहीं कर रहा। ऑब्वियसली सब
सब कर रहे हैं। सब कर रहे हैं ना बट उसकी
टेक्नोलॉजी हमें नहीं पता या सुनी होगी और
आज एज ए डीएचई डेफेंस एकेडमी हम इसको
समझाएंगे और इस पे हम बहुत सारी चीजें
सीखेंगे। हमारा जो एजेंडा क्या है? आज वो
हम बात करने वाले हैं कि हमारा एजेंडा
क्या रहेगा इसका नेक्स्ट अपकमिंग क्लासेस
में इसके ऊपर वो भी हम बात करेंगे। ओके तो
एक और चीज बता देता हूं जो वेब की जो
टेक्नोलॉजी है वो नई नहीं है। और जो जब से
आईटी इंडस्ट्री है तब से वेब की
टेक्नोलॉजी एकिस्ट करती है। तब इसको
अलग-अलग तरीके से यूज़ किया जाता है। इसका
यूज़ करने का तरीका अलग था। इस तब बहुत
सारी कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी थी। कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी
अभी भी है। ईजी टेक्नोलॉजी नहीं है। बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स टेक्नोलॉजी है। इसको समझना भी
इसको एनालाइज भी करना। बट हम क्या है कि
देख सकते हैं कि कैसे की जाती है। बट उस
टाइम पे क्या है कि इतनी ज्यादा एडवांस
टेक्नोलॉजी नहीं थी कि हम वप को ज्यादा
फ्रीक्वेंटली यूज़ कर पाए। बट व नया नहीं
है। यह मत समझना कि वप बिलकुल नया है। तो
इसलिए हम बता देते हैं कि टुडे ऑल
एंटरप्राइजेस लार्ज एंड स्मॉल डिपेंड ऑन
वप टू प्रोवाइड वॉइस कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन
इंटरनली एंड एक्सटर्नली टू द कंपनी। आज के
टाइम पर ऑलमोस्ट हर एक एंटरप्राइज चाहे
छोटी कंपनी हो, चाहे बड़ी कंपनी हो, वप का
यूज करती है। वप का मेन काम क्या है? वॉइस
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोवाइड करना। मतलब फोन
कॉल्स, आपके वॉइस मीटिंग्स, आपके स्पॉट
कॉल्स, आपकी हेल्प डोस सबको मैनेज करता है
आपका वो कंपनी के अंदर भी या कंपनी के
बाहर क्लाइंट के साथ बात करनी हो,
कांटेक्ट करना हो या कस्टमर के साथ बात
करनी हो या वेंडर से भी बात करनी हो
एक्सटर्नली वह भी वॉइस कॉल के द्वारा ही
किया जाता है। तो मोस्ट ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
इवन हैव डेडिकेटेड वॉइस व्ही लेंस एंड और
फिजिकल पोर्ट टू कैरी वॉइस ट्रैफिक। अभी
हम कह सकते हैं कि जो ट्रेडिशनल फोन लाइंस
की जगह पर नेटवर्क बेस्ड वॉइस
कम्युनिकेशंस का यूज किया जाता है। कई
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन क्या करती है? वब के लिए एक
सेपरेट इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर बनाती है। जैसे कि
डेडिकेटेड वॉइस व्ही लाइन उन्होंने बना ली
कि ताकि जो वॉइस पैकेट है वो स्पेसिफिकली
उसी अह वी लाइन के थ्रू कैरी किया जा सके।
या डेडिकेटेड फिजिकल पोर्ट्स मतलब कि हम
कह सकते हैं कि किसी स्विच के अंदर कुछ
स्पेसिफिक IP फोन के लिए या स्पेसिफिक व
कॉल के लिए पोर्ट रिजर्व कर दिए गए हैं
ताकि वहां से आपकी वॉइप कॉलिंग हो सके। अब
इससे बेनिफिट क्या होगा कि जो वब ट्रैफिक
है वो नेटवर्क से आइसोलेट हो जाएगा जिससे
परफॉर्मेंस का इशू है और जो सिक्योरिटी का
इशू है दोनों में इंप्रूवमेंट होगा। मतलब
कंपनी क्या करती है कि वेब को इतना
सीरियसली ट्रीट करती हैं कि वो अलग से
नेटवर्क सेगमेंट का यूज करती है इसके लिए।
समझ रहे हो कि मैं आपको जो बताने की कोशिश
कर रहा हूं। तो इसीलिए जो व है वप को
समझना काफी इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाता है कि वप
का ट्रैफिक कैसा होता है? कौन-कौन से
प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज़ किए जाते हैं? क्या-क्या
सिक्योरिटी रिस्क होते हैं? इंक्रिप्शन
कैसे होता है? फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस के टाइम
पर उसको डिक्रिप्ट कैसे किया जाता है? ये
सारी चीजें आपको समझना काफी जरूरी है। अगर
मैं बात करूं एज अ रेड टीमर तो रेड टीमर
क्या कर सकता है? रेट टीमर क्या कर सकता
है? कॉल को कैप्चर कर सकता है। ऑडियो को
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकता है। क्रेडेंशियल्स को
थप्ट करके देख सकता है या जो शिप सर्वर
होता है जो सर्वर है उसको टेक ओवर करने की
कोशिश कर सकता है। या फिर हम बात करें
ब्लू ट्रीमिंग में क्या होता है? जो ब्लू
ट्रीमिंग क्या करेंगे? उस वप अटैक को
डिटेक्ट करने की कोशिश करेंगे। उसको
डिटेक्ट डिटेक्शन लगाएंगे। वहां पर रूल्स
अप्लाई करेंगे। टू स्टैपिक को एनालाइज
करेंगे। कॉल लॉक्स को ऑडिट करेंगे। जो
इंक्रिप्शनंस है उसको वेरीफाई करना किसका
होता है? ब्लू टेमिंग का काम होता है। अगर
मैं बात करूं फॉरेंसिक इन्वेस्टर के
फॉरेंसिक में जो इन्वेस्टिगेस्टर्स होते
हैं वो क्या करते हैं? वॉइस पैकेट को
डिकेड डिकोड करेंगे। डिकोड करके क्या
करेंगे? जो उसकी टाइमलाइन है प्लस में जो
ऑडियो एविडेंस है उसको प्रोड्यूस करने के
लिए यूज़ करते हैं। तो इसलिए मैं आपको यह
भी यह बताऊं कि जो सेक्शन जो स्टार्ट होने
जा रहा है आपका वब से रिगार्डिंग वो इतना
इंपॉर्टेंट है कि जहां पर आपको यह देखने
को मिला कि वब की इंटरनल वर्किंग क्या है?
प्रोटोकॉल लेवल एनालिसिस कैसे किया जाता
है? पैकेट को कैप्चर्स, उसका डिक्रिप्शन,
ऑडियो एक्सट्रैक्शन मतलब उसके सैंपल्स हैं
मेरे पास जो आप देख पाओगे क्योंकि इसके
लिए डेडिकेटेड लैब कहीं पर भी नहीं है। बट
हमारे पास सैंपल है कि जब सैंपल कैप्चर कर
लेंगे तो उस सैंपल्स को आप कैसे एनालाइज
कर सकते हो। जब आप रियल एंटरप्राइज
एनवायरमेंट में जाओगे और आपको अगर व की
सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग करनी पड़ जाए तो आपको
उस टाइप के सैंपल्स आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे। ओके? उस टाइप के सैंपल्स आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे। तो इसलिए मैं आपको बोल
रहा हूं कि चाहे आप चाहे प्रोफेशनल
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर हो, चाहे आप
पेंटस्टर्स हो, फॉरेंसिक हो, शो केस्ट हो,
सबको वप के बारे में पता होना चाहिए
क्योंकि काफी इंपॉर्टेंट सेक्शन है और यही
चीज हम प्रैक्टिकली भी देखेंगे। तो एक चीज
समझ में आया कि एजेंडा क्या है या क्या
चीज मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं।
कोई भी सवाल है मुझसे पूछ लेना। मैं एंड
में सारे सवाल आपके लूंगा। डोंट वरी चिंता
करने की जरूरत नहीं है बिल्कुल भी कि आज
मैं बता देता हूं। सेशन ज्यादा लंबा नहीं
लेंगे क्योंकि व को हम बिल्कुल प्यार से
आराम से स्लो स्लो थोड़ा आराम से समझाएंगे
क्योंकि नई टेक्नोलॉजी आप लोगों के लिए आप
लोगों को नहीं पता होगा चीजें समझने में
थोड़ी सी टफ लगेंगी फर्स्ट टाइम तो हम
धीरेधी धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ेंगे ओके तो ऐसा
है कि कोई जल्दबाजी नहीं करेंगे और मैं
इसको एज ए रेगुलर क्लास ट्रीट करूंगा डेली
क्लास नहीं बट आई विल ट्राई कि इसमें
ज्यादा गैप नहीं दूंगा ताकि आप लोग चीजों
को भूलो ना और उस कांसेप्ट को क्लियर भी
कर पाओ। इस इसको इसलिए मैं कोशिश करूंगा
कि ज्यादा से ज्यादा इसकी क्लास
कंटीन्यूअस टाइप की ही रखूं कि जैसे क्लास
होती है। समझ में आ गई? तो इसमें मैं
ज्यादा गैप देने की कोशिश नहीं करूंगा। तो
अभी हम बात करते हैं कि हमारे जो सेक्शन
का एजेंडा क्या हो सकता है? कि जो मैं
आपको पढ़ाऊंगा आज की क्लास के बाद को
हमारा एजेंडा क्या रहेगा। एजेंडे में सबसे
पहले हम बात करेंगे वही प्रोटोकॉल बेसिक
के बारे में। सबसे पहले हम देखेंगे कि जो
वही प्रोटोकॉल्स है उसका डीप इंट्रोडक्शन
करेंगे। डीपली समझेंगे क्या होता है।
क्योंकि बिना प्रोटोकॉल को समझे आप
सिक्योरिटी एनालिसिस नहीं कर सकते। पॉसिबल
ही नहीं है। अगर आपको प्रोटोकॉल की नॉलेज
नहीं है तो आप उसका एनालिसिस नहीं कर
सकते। जिसमें मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा कि शिप
क्या होता है? आरटीपी क्या होता है?
मीडिया या जो सिग्नलिंग यूज़ होती है इनके
बीच में या यह किस तरीके से परफॉर्म होता
है? है उसकी आर्किटेक्चर किस तरह का उसका
डिजाइन है वो चीज मैं आपको समझाऊंगा और
साथ के साथ जहां पर प्रैक्टिकल पॉसिबल हो
पाया हम उसको प्रैक्टिकली भी देखेंगे तो
सेकंड हम क्या देखेंगे वफ ट्रैफिक
कॉम्बिनेशन
अब वहां पर हम चार इंपॉर्टेंट कॉम्बिनेशन
को स्टडी करेंगे हमारे यहां पर सबसे पहला
शिप प्लस में आरटीपी मतलब बोथ अनइंकिप्टेड
मतलब आपकी जो वॉइस कॉल हो रही है वह
बिल्कुल प्लेन टेक्स्ट में कॉल हो रही है
जो अटैकर्स के लिए गोल्ड माइन होता
दूसरा क्या है? शिप ओवर टीएलएस प्लस में
आरटीपी। शिप ओवर टीएलएस का मतलब क्या है?
कि आपका जो शिप है वह इंक्रिप्टेड है और
जो आरटीपी है जो मीडिया सर्वर है वो आपका
क्या है? अनइंकिप्टेड है। इंक्रिप्टेड
नहीं है। मतलब इसमें आपकी जो वॉइस है वह
अनइंकिप्टेड फॉर्म में जा रही है। कोई भी
कैप्चर कर लेगा। थर्ड जो कॉम्बिनेशन हम
देखेंगे शिप प्लस में एसआरटीपी मतलब अब की
बार क्या है कि जो शिप है वह अनइंकिप्टेड
है एसआरटीपी जो आपका वॉइस कॉल है वो
इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में जाएगा वो हम
देखेंगे एनालाइज करके शिप ओवर टीएलएस प्लस
में एसआरटीपी फुल्ली इंक्रिप्टेड मतलब
दोनों ही इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में जो आपका
स्टार्टिंग का जो कनेक्शन है या आपकी जो
वॉइस कॉल है वह दोनों दोनों पूरी
इंक्रिप्टेड और यह सबसे सिक्योर माना जाता
है। यह सबसे सिक्योर माना जाता है। तो, हर
कॉम्बिनेशन को हम क्या करेंगे? एनालाइज़
करना देखेंगे। एनालाइज़ करके देखेंगे। अगर
उसके पैकेट के स्ट्रक्चर्स देखेंगे और
प्रैक्टिकल कवर करने की कोशिश करेंगे। और
यह जो हम एनालिसिस के लिए फाइल्स का यूज़
करेंगे। जो सैंपल फाइल्स हमारे पास है
जिनका हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। वो मैं आपको
अपने आर्टिकल के थ्रू प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा।
जहां से आप उसको एक्सेस कर पाओगे, डाउनलोड
कर पाओगे या मैं आपको बता दूंगा। कहां से
रिसोर्सेज को आप एक्सेस कर सकते हो ताकि
आप खुद से भी प्रैक्टिस कर पाओ। इसकी भी
चिंता मत करना कि आप हम कहां से प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे। ओके?
उसके बाद नेक्स्ट हम क्या करने वाले हैं
इसमें? कि वफ ट्रैफिक टाइप्स के बारे में
देखने वाले हैं। उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे?
जो आपका रियल इंटर जो इंटरप्राइज
एनवायरमेंट है उसमें डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट की
वफ ट्रैफिक
होती हैं। जैसे आपका वॉइस मेल ट्रैफिक हो
गया, टू कॉलर नॉर्मल कॉल हो गई,
कॉन्फ्रेंस कॉल होगी, शिप मैसेज ट्रैफिक
हो गया। ये इनके बारे में हम क्या करेंगे?
इसका भी हम इसके भी सिनेरियो को लेंगे। हम
देखेंगे कि क्या इंक्रिप्शन हो रहा है?
क्या लीक हो सकता है? फॉरेंसिक अप्रोच
क्या हम फॉलो कर सकते हैं? डिक्रिप्शन
अप्लाई हो सकता है नहीं हो सकता। मतलब ये
चीजें भी हम क्या करेंगे? एक बार देख
देखेंगे कि कैसे-कैसे चीजें परफॉर्म की
जाती हैं। उसके बाद हम देखेंगे वप कॉल
डिक्रिप्शन टेक्निक। यहां पर हम क्या काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग प्रैक्टिकल होगा जिसमें हम
ट्राई करेंगे कि जो वॉइप कॉल है उसको
डिक्रिप्ट करने की कि हम वहां पर सीखेंगे
कि कब
कब इंक्रिप्शन पॉसिबल है, कब इंपॉसिबल है,
क्या की मिल सकती है या नहीं मिल सकती?
क्या मिसिंग हो सकता है? कुछ टूल्स
एकिस्टिंग टूल्स अगर अवेलेबल्स हैं तो या
व्स आर को कैसे हम इसको यूज करना है? यह
सारी चीजें हम इस सेक्शन में सीखने वाले
हैं। उसके बाद नेक्स्ट हमारा क्या रहेगा?
वॉइप रजिस्टर मैसेज एनालिसिस। मतलब एंड
में एक काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है जिसका
नाम है शिप रजिस्टर मैसेज क्रैकिंग। मतलब
क्या है कि हम देखेंगे कि जो शिप
रजिस्टर्स के जो मैसेज होते हैं, शिप के
अंदर जो रजिस्टर है, रजिस्टर करते वक्त जो
मैसेजेस होते हैं, उनके अंदर जो हैश
प्रेजेंट होते हैं, उनको हम कैप्चर कैसे
कर सकते हैं? उनको एक्सट्रैक्ट कैसे कर
सकते हैं? या उनको उनका पासवर्ड क्रैक
करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं। कैसे कर सकते
हैं? ये सारी चीजें तो और उससे हम वप
अकाउंट को कैसे कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हैं। मैं आई एम नॉट गारंटीड
कि हम कर पाएंगे बट कर कैसे सकते हैं? बस
हम अप्रोच देखेंगे वो सारी चीजें बिल्कुल
एक यही आपकी एक रेड टीमिंग प्रैक्टिस है
सबसे बेस्ट। तो उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्या है?
कुछ नहीं। नेक्स्ट वही है। तो एक छोटा सा
होम सेटअप लैब देखेंगे अगर पॉसिबल हुआ तो
हम बना पाए तो वह भी हम अपनी काली लinक्स
के अंदर वह सारी चीजें हम क्या करेंगे?
देखने वाले तो कहने का मतलब क्या है? एंड
ऑफ द कॉस्ट आपके लिए जो वब की जो
टेक्नोलॉजी है, जो वप कॉल है, वह आपके लिए
ब्लैक बॉक्स नहीं रहेगा। आप यह भी समझ
पाओगे सिग्नलिंग जो सिग्नलिंग होती है,
उसको समझ पाओगे। उसके मीडिया फ्लो को
डिकोड कर पाओगे। पॉसिबल हुआ तो इंक्रिप्शन
को ब्रेक करने की कोशिश कर पाओगे।
फॉरेंसिक लेवल पर अगर आप एनालिसिस कर पाए
तो वह भी कर पाओगे। तो ये सारी चीजें तो
आई कैन से दैट कि एक चीज मैं आपको बोलूंगा
कि आप रेड टीमिंग हो या ब्लू टीमिंग में
हो या इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस हो यह जो वप वाला
जो सेक्शन हम कवर करने वाले हैं सबके लिए
तो बॉस आपको समझ में आ गया कि इस सेक्शन
का एजेंडा क्या है
जो इंट्रोडक्शन मैंने आपको बताया तो सबको
समझ में आया कि अह मैं आपको क्या-क्या कवर
करने वाला हूं और एक्चुअली क्या-क्या
बताने वाला हूं और इतना पता कि सचिन सर इस
चीज को पढ़ा रहे हैं। वो कितना डीप में
जाते हैं सबको पता है। उस चीज के लिए तो
आपको बिल्कुल सोचने की जरूरत ही नहीं है
कि सचिन सर किसी चीज को छोड़ दें। वो जाते
डीप में ही है। आपको जो टॉपिक मैं
पढ़ाऊंगा तो मुझे चाहे उसकी हिस्ट्री से
क्यों ना स्टार्ट करना पड़े बस मैं उसको
स्टार्ट करता हूं। हां जो चीज नहीं पढ़ा
रहा हूं नहीं पढ़ा रहा हूं वो बात अलग है।
अब आप अगर इस पे कुछ पूछना चाहते हो पूछ
लो। 1 मिनट है। उसके बाद थोड़ा सा
इंट्रोडक्शन करेंगे कि वही होता क्या है?
बिल्कुल थोड़ा सा अह उसकी कुछ स्लाइड्स
हैं। उसके बाद हम सेशन को एंड भी करेंगे।
बट टाइम है अभी स्लाइड्स हैं मेरे पास
इंट्रोडक्शन कि वप उसके यह है हमारा
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक इंट्रोडक्शन टू वप वप होता
क्या है उसकी टेक्नोलॉजी क्या है बिल्कुल
मतलब होता क्या है उसके बारे में जानेंगे
सबसे पहले तो किसी कोई सवाल है तो मुझसे
पूछो कुछ डाउट है सर क्या यह भी होगा यह
नहीं होगा जो मुझसे पूछना चाहते हो आप वो
पूछ सकते हो कि जो आपके एक्सपेक्टेशन है
इस सेक्शन से क्या वह आप वह शायद मुझसे
पूछ सकते हो
किसी कोई एक्सपेक्टेशन है मुझसे तो बताइए।
एक्सपेक्टेशन नहीं है तो नो कर दीजिए तो
यस या नो का जवाब तो जल्दी से दीजिए। कोई
एक्सपेक्टेशन है तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हो।
मतलब जो अभी तक मैंने आपको बताया वह
बिल्कुल क्लिस्ट क्रिस्टल क्लियर है कि
आपको यह चीज पता है कि व्हाट वी आर गोइंग
टू लर्न है ना कि हम क्या सीखने जा रहे
हैं। बिल्कुल यह चीज सबको क्लियर है।
बाकी अभी भी मैं खुश नहीं हूं कि आप 30 ही
स्टूडेंट आए हो यार।
सबको बताऊंगा जगत गुरु जी हम जो नेक्स्ट
क्लास स्टार्ट करेंगे वो स्टार्ट करेंगे
सीधा प्रैक्टिकल प्लस में थ्योरेटिकल जो
भी कुछ है हम बिल्कुल अच्छे से करेंगे
आपको बताया गोविंद प्रैक्टिकल लैब नहीं
सेटअप कर सकते बट वी विल ट्राई कि कोई कर
पाए तो क्योंकि वब के टेक्नोलॉजी इतनी
कॉम्प्लेक्स है तो आपको बस मैं बता सकता
हूं एज ए रेटिमर हम उसको कैसे एनालाइज कर
सकते हैं।
मैं समझा नहीं आप क्या पूछ रहे थे सर यह
फुल वीडियो मिलेगा ना? आई डोंट नो कि क्या
कहने की कोशिश कर रहे हो।
मैं समझा नहीं कि आप क्या बोल रहे हो।
कौन से सर ने कैसे नहीं बताया था। आई एम
नॉट एबल टू अंडरस्टैंड कि आप मुझसे क्या
सॉल्व कर रहे हो। थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लोर कर
सकते हो आपके अपने क्वेश्चन को आप।
अदरवाइज हम स्टार्ट करेंगे।
लाइव डिलीट क्यों होगी?
मैं कोई इललीगल काम थोड़ी ना कर रहा हूं।
मैं कोई भी इललीगल काम नहीं कर रहा।
चलिए
नाउ इंट्रोडक्शन व के बारे में। व स्टैंड
फॉर वॉइस ओवर इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल एंड इट इज
इट सिंपली मींस ट्रांसमिटिंग योर वॉइस ओवर
एन आईपी एड्रेस। वब का मतलब वब स्टैंड फॉर
वब का फुल फॉर्म है वॉइस ओवर इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल। और इसका यूज़ किया जाता है कि
जो आपकी वॉइस है जो हम बात करते हैं उसको
इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल के जरिए जो आईपी
नेटवर्क है उसके जरिए क्या किया जाए?
ट्रांसमिट किया जाए। एक पर्सन से दूसरे
पर्सन तक या बोले एक व्यक्ति से दूसरे
व्यक्ति तक या एक प्लेस से दूसरे प्लेस
तक। इन ट्रेडिशनल टेलीफोनी योर वॉइस
ट्रेवल थ्रू डेडिकेटेड कॉपर वायर्स एंड
टेलीफोन सर्किट। इससे पहले क्या होता था
कि जो आपकी जो वॉइस थी वो वायर के थ्रू
ट्रैवल करती थी। कॉपर वायर के थ्रू और
टेलीफ़ोन सर्किट के थ्रू ट्रैवल करती थी।
बट इन वॉइप योर वॉइस इज कन्व्टेड इंटू
डिजिटल डेटा पैकेट्स व्हिच ट्रैवल अक्रॉस
द इंटरनेट जस्ट लाइक ईमेल्स इमेजज़ एंड एनी
अदर फॉर्म ऑफ नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक। बिल्कुल
सही है कि जो आपकी वॉइस है जो भी आप बात
करते हो उसको क्या है कि पहले डिजिटल डाटा
पैकेट में कन्वर्ट कर दिया जाता है। उसके
बाद उसको इनकोड कर दिया जाता है। इनकोड
करके उसको क्या किया कंप्रेस कर दिया जाता
है। कंप्रेस करके बिल्कुल मल्टीपल पैकेट्स
में उसको तोड़ दिया जाता है। जो बिल्कुल
ऐसे ट्रैवल करता है जैसे आपके ईमेल्स हैं,
आपके इमेजज़ हैं, जो आपका नॉर्मल डाटा
ट्रेवल करता है, वैसे ही आपके जो वॉइस के
डाटा है, वह भी ट्रैवल करते हैं नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक के अंदर। उसके बाद वप रिलाइज ऑन द
सेम इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर ऑलरेडी यूज फॉर
इंटरनेट कम्युनिकेशन। अब जो आपका वाइप है
वह सस्ता क्यों है? इतना चीप क्यों है? वो
इन्हीं कारणों से सस्ता है। क्योंकि जो
आपका जो व है वो कौन सी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
को यूज़ करता है जो ऑलरेडी आप यूज़ कर रहे
हो। इंटरनेट कम्युनिकेशन आपका आईपी एड्रेस
आपके राउटर्स, आपके स्विचेस, फायरवॉल्स,
वाई-फाई, व्हीलेंस इन्हीं का यूज़ कर रहा
है आपका वही। इट इंटीग्रेट टेलीफोन इनू द
एकिस्टिंग आईटी इकोसिस्टम। इसने क्या कर
दिया कि जो आपका ऑलरेडी एकिस्टिंग आईटी
इकोसिस्टम था उसी के अंदर इस टेक्नोलॉजी
को इंटीग्रेट कर दिया गया टेलीफोन वाली को
अलग से कोई डेडिकेटेड सर्किट नहीं कोई
डेडिकेटेड लाइन नहीं डेडिकेटली कुछ चीज
हैंडल करनी ही नहीं तो आप सोचो कि इन इतने
पैसे क्यों नहीं लगाने जो जो टेक्नोलॉजी
को इतनी आसानी से ऑलरेडी यूजिंग जो
इकोसिस्टम उसके अंदर इंटरप्रेट कर दिया
जाए। ओके नेक्स्ट टू मेजर कंपोनेंट्स ऑफ
वप वप के दो मेजर कंपोनेंट्स हैं। एक तो
क्या है शिप आपका मैं आपको बताऊंगा कि
डिटेल में बताऊंगा बिल्कुल क्या होता है।
शिप क्या करता है? हैंडल ऑल शिप हैंडल ऑल
द कंट्रोल फंक्शनंस ऑफ ए कॉल। जब आप कॉल
करते हो सारे कंट्रोल फंक्शन जैसे कि कौन
कॉल कौन किसको कॉल कर रहा है? रिंग जो
रिंग आपकी भरती है वह भी एक्सेप्ट करना
रिजेक्ट करना किसी कॉल को सेशन को सेटअप
करना सेशन को मैनेजमेंट करना उसके बाद उस
कॉल को डिस्कनेक्ट करना ये जो सारे
फंक्शनंस हैं इन सबको जो कंट्रोल करने का
काम है वो आपका शिप प्रोटोकॉल का है तो
सबसे पहले जो कंपोनेंट है जो शिप
प्रोटोकॉल है वो है उसका काम क्या है कि
कौन किसको कॉल कर रहा है कब रिंग बजेगी
उसके लिए सेशन सेटअप करना सेशन को मैनेज
करना उसके लिए कॉल को कट करना रिजेक्ट
करना एक्सेप्ट करना यह सारे काम किसका काम
शिप प्रोटोकॉल का काम है। ओके। उसके बाद
आरटीपी। आरटीपी आपका क्या है? मीडिया
प्रोटोकॉल है। आरटीपी क्या करता है? आपका
जो एक्चुअल वॉइस डाटा है जो आप बात कर रहे
हो उसको कैरी करता है। और जब एक बार कब
कैरी करता है? जब शिप प्रोटोकॉल उसको क्या
कर देता है? इस्टैब्लिश कर देता है। वह
पूरा सेटअप कर लेता है। उसके बाद क्या
होता है कि जो आरटीपी प्रोटोकॉल इसका यूज़
किया जाता है और आपका जो डिजिटल डाटा है
जो डिजिटल वॉइस पैकेट है उसको आरटीपी के
थ्रू क्या किया जाता है? ट्रांसफर कर दिया
जाता है। तो एग्जांपल्स कौन-कौन से हैं
आपके? Google mट्स है, Microsoft टीम है,
ZM है, डिस्कर्ड है, WhatsApp है, SAP सब
क्या करते हैं? आपके वेब टेक्नोलॉजी का
यूज़ करते हैं। दैट्स ऑल। ये था आपका सेशन
जो मैं आपको बताना चाहता था।
यह है आपका रियल टाइम ट्रांसपोर्ट
प्रोटोकॉल
आरटीपी और मैं बताऊंगा कि आरटीपी कैसे काम
करता है, कैसे है। पूरा जो डेफिनेशंस है
सब कुछ बताऊंगा। जो आज के सेशन का मेन जो
मेरा पर्पस था वो पर्पस था कि मैं आपको यह
बताऊं कि हम क्या पढ़ने वाले हैं।
मैं आपको यह बताऊं कि हम पढ़ने क्या वाले
हैं। उसके बाद हम देखेंगे कि
नेक्स्ट सेक्शन क्या होगा। बट ए सेक्शन
में कुछ क्लासेस आएंगी और मैं उम्मीद कर
सकता हूं कि हर क्लास में स्टूडेंट की
कंसिस्टेंसी मेंटेन रहे। स्टूडेंट क्लास
को छोड़ के ना जाएं क्योंकि इट्स वेरीेंट।
तो अभी चाहो तो आप कुछ भी पूछ सकते हो।
मैं आपकी चैट देख रहा हूं। तो आपकी जो भी
क्वरी है आई एम रेडी टू सॉल्व। उसके बाद
अदरवाइज नॉट रिक्वायर्ड टू सॉल्व योर
क्वरीज।
बताओ वन बाय वन जो भी आपकी क्वरी है पूछ
सकते हो। आज का टॉपिक इतना ही था। मेन
मेरा मोटिव था कि आज को आपका एजेंडा बताना
कि हम इस कोर्स में क्या कवर करने वाले
हैं। देखो पीडीएफ कहां मिलते हैं दिनेश
शर्मा तो मैं आपको बताता हूं। आप नए हो तो
एक मेरा मीडियम मीडियम पे आर्टिकल्स हैं।
फॉलो कर लीजिए। जो मेरा मीडियम का मैं
आपको बता देता हूं। मीडियम अकाउंट है
मेरा। मीडियम इस पे नहीं होगा। आई थिंक आई
एम नॉट एबल टू शो इट।
जैसे कि ये मेरा लेटेस्ट आर्टिकल्स है। तो
यहां पर जाओगे। आप इनको मैं आप ग्रुप में
भेज रहा हूं। तो यहां पर मैं अपने जितने
भी नोट्स हैं सारे नोट्स को यहीं पर क्या
करने वाला हूं? शेयर करने वाला हूं। लगभग
इन फ्यूचर्स भी अभी भी। ओके? तो आप यहां
से इन आर्टिकल्स को फॉलो कर लीजिए,
सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिए ईमेल पर। सो दैट कि
उससे क्या होगा कि जब भी मैं आर्टिकल्स
ल्च करूंगा तो आर्टिकल्स आपको मिल जाएगा
और यह जो नोट्स मैं आपको पढ़ाता हूं लाइव
क्लास में वो सारे नोट्स आपको यहां पे भी
देखने को मिल जाएंगे। ओके और किसी
बिल्कुल मैं इस सीरीज को कंटिन्यू करूंगा
और बिल्कुल 100% कंटिन्यू करूंगा। अगर
स्टूडेंट्स आते रहेंगे इस सीरीज को हम ऐसे
लेवल पर लेकर जाएंगे आपको जो आपको कुछ
कहता है इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक आपको कुछ
पढ़ने की जरूरत नहीं होगी सिर्फ यहां से
पढ़ो एग्जाम दो बस
नहीं वयरलेस हैकिंग में नहीं आता व इज अ
टोटली डिफरेंट टॉपिक वायरलेस भी हम
सीखेंगे वह भी है हमारे प्लान में
देखो बग बंटी आप लोगों के एक चीज क्लियर
नहीं है कि बग बंटीज
और क्या चीजें? आइए बताओ कितने लोग यह
मानते हैं कि पेन टेस्टिंग या रेड टीमिंग
में जो बग बंटी है वह उसके अंदर आती है।
उसका पार्ट है। बताओ कितने लोग हैं?
कितने लोग मानते हैं इस चीज को?
चलो मैं आपसे बात कर रहा हूं कि कितने लोग
इस चीज को मानते हैं कि पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग में का पेट टेस्टिंग में जो बग
बाउंट है वो उसका पार्ट है। कितने लोग इस
चीज को मानते हो?
कितने लोग मानते हैं इस चीज को? या नहीं
मानते वह भी बता दो।
लाइव सेशन मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं का
असली नाम मुझे नहीं पता कि टिक्स रबर
लाइव को हमेशा देखो। प्रीवियस सेक्शन में
हो मैं मान गया। प्रीवियस सेक्शन वाले आप
करो बट लाइव को हमेशा देखो क्योंकि लाइव
में बहुत कुछ होता है और जब आप लाइव देखते
हो तो आपको प्रीवियस करने की जो रुचि होती
है ना ज्यादा बढ़ती है।
मैं मानता हूं सब बग बंटी इज अ
फ्रीलांसिंग वर्क नो फ्रॉम नो फॉर्म माय
साइड।
अब तो समझ में आ गया ना जो पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग्स है उसमें बहुत सारे सेक्शंस
हैं। मैं आपको बता देता हूं। पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग में आता है। आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग पूरी होती है। मैं आपको एक चीज
बताता हूं। देखो आपको बिल्कुल क्लियर कर
दूंगा और इन फ्यूचर जब मैं कभी चीजें और
भी बताऊंगा तब ज्यादा बिल्कुल क्लेरिटी हो
जाएगी आप डायग्राम की। एक चीज बताता हूं।
अभी जो पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते हो कई
तरीके से करते हो आप। इंटरनल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग जहां पर क्या है कि इंटरनेट पर
कुछ भी एक्सपोज नहीं है। पूरी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस की आप इंटरनल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग करते हो। मतलब इंटरनेट से वह
कनेक्टेड नहीं है। समझ में आ गया? पहली
बात इंटरनेट से वह कनेक्टेड नहीं है। आप
क्या आपको क्या किया? उस नेटवर्क का पार्ट
बना दिया गया। आप उस नेटवर्क को टेस्ट
कीजिए। उस नेटवर्क के अंदर वनेबिलिटी
ढूंढिए। उस नेटवर्क को यह चेक कीजिए कि वो
लेटेस्ट जितने भी वनेबिलिटीज है उससे पैच
है या नहीं है या आप उसको अटैक कर पाओगे
नहीं कर पाओगे। एक तरीका यह हो गया। मतलब
यह इंटरनल पेस्ट है। आप ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
अंदर हो। ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का पार्ट हो। आप
उसको टेस्ट कर पा रहे हो। आप
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस ने ही आपको बोला है। मतलब
आपके पास क्या है? उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
नेटवर्क का एक्सेस है। यू आर अ पार्ट ऑफ
दैट नेटवर्क। सेकंड पार्ट क्या हो गया?
सेकंड पार्ट आता है आपका एक्सटर्नल पेन
टेस्टिंग। मतलब क्या है कि ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
ने बोला कि यह मेरी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है।
ओके? मेरी यह वेबसाइट है एक्सपोज। बस मैं
आपको इतना ही बताऊंगा। अब आप दोनों काम
कीजिए। आप एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग भी करो
और अगर आप इसके बेस पर इंटरनल एंटर कर
पाते हो तो आप इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग भी
कीजिए। समझ में आ गया? दूसरा पहलू क्या
स्टार्ट हुआ? एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग। अब
एक चीज बताओ छोटी सी बात मेरे को कि अगर
आपको आप ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस का पार्ट नहीं हो
और बिना ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के पार्ट के आप
किसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस को अटैक करना चाहते
हो तो कैसे कर सकते हो?
मल्टीपल वेज़ हैं। पहला तरीका कौन सा है?
आप क्या करोगे? या तो यह चीज पता करो कि
इंटरनेट पर उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का एक्सपोज
क्या है? मतलब कि कोई सर्वर उसका एक्सपोज
है। कोई वेबसाइट तो यूज़ कर रही होगी ना।
अब वो टोटली डिफरेंट चीज है कि
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ने कि जो वेब वेब सर्वर है
और इंटरनेट को सेपरेट रखा होगा। बट वह
तरीका है। एक तो वह तरीका है। वह भी पेन
टेस्टिंग का पार्ट है। पेन टेस्टिंग छोटी
चीज नहीं है। पेन टेस्टिंग बहुत बड़ा
डोमेन है।
ओके। पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग बहुत बड़ा डोमेन
है अपने आप में। तो आपको बताया इंटरनल
एक्सटर्नल एक्सटर्नल में आ गया आपका कि
आपने
क्या किया?
आपने वेब पेन टेस्टिंग की। वेब पन
टेस्टिंग को ज्यादातर लोग एज ए
फ्रीलांसिंग क्या बोलते हैं? बग बाउंट।
ओके? पेन टेस्टिंग में और बग बाउंट में
अंतर क्या है? मैं बता देता हूं। पेन
टेस्टिंग के अंदर टाइम बाउंड होता है
और बग बाउंट जैसी चीजें होती हैं उनमें
टाइम बाउंड नहीं होता। टाइम बाउंड का मतलब
क्या है? कि अगर आप किसी चीज की पेन
टेस्टिंग करते हो तो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन आपको
वक्त देती है कि आपको वन वीक में कंप्लीट
करनी है, वन मंथ में कंप्लीट करनी है, 15
डेज में कंप्लीट करनी है। आपके पास
डेडलाइन होती है टाइम की। लेकिन जब बात
करते हैं कि बग बाउंटी की बग बाउंट एज ए
फ्रीलांस आपके पास कोई टाइम बाउंड नहीं
होता। आप एक वबिलिटी पर एक महीना स्पेंड
करो 2 महीना स्पेंड करो एक साल स्पेंड करो
या उस टारगेट पे एक साल लगाओ वो टोटली
डिपेंड्स ऑन यू नो टाइम बाउंट। समझ में आ
गया? इसलिए जो बग बाउंटी है
या वेब पेन टेस्टिंग को आप बग बाउंट भी
बोल सकते हो क्योंकि वेब पेन टेस्टिंग में
आप क्या करते हो वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस की
वनेबिलिटी टेस्ट करते हो बग बाउंट में
क्या करते हो आप वेब एप्लीकेशन की पन
टेस्ट वेब एप्लीकेशन जो वबिलिटी वो भी आप
भी सेम काम करते हो सेम टूल रन करते हो
सेम चीज करते हो वही डो डोमेन सब डोमेन
वही टूल आप यूज़ करने वाले हो वही वनबिलिटी
फाइंड आउट करने वाले हो तो डिफरेंस क्या
रह गया बट बट जो बग बाउंट है या वेब पेन
टेस्टिंग है बस एक में टाइम बाउंड है एक
में टाइम बाउंड नहीं है और दोनों पार्ट
किसका है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का दो चीजें
बताई मैंने अब एक्सटर्नल में वेब सर्वर्स
की बात आ गई सेकंड क्या चीज आ गई अब दूसरा
उस ऑर्गेन को कैसे टेस्ट कर सकते हो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं ना
क्लाइंट सैड अटैक वह भी हम बात करने वाले
हैं इस कोर्स में वह भी हम बात करेंगे
क्लाइंट सेड अटैक क्लाइंट साइड अटैक का
पार्ट क्या होता है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक का पार्ट होता है। मतलब
कि आपको अगर यह भी चेक करना है कि भाई
ऑर्गेनाइज ठीक है? सर्वर सही है, इंटरनेट
सही है, जो एंप्लॉय काम कर रहे हैं। अब उन
पे ट्रस्ट करना है ना तो वहां पर क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक आते हैं। क्लाइंट साइड अटैक में
क्या करते हो आप? पेलोड रेडी करते हो।
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हो। पर तरीका
क्या होता है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के जरिए।
समझ में आई? मैं जो चीज़ आपको बता रहा हूं
आज। देखो, मैं वैसे नॉर्मली बताता नहीं।
आज हमारे पास टाइम था ना तो मैं आपको
चीजें एक्सप्लोर कर देता हूं। चीजें
एक्सप्लोर कर देता हूं कि आप लोगों के जो
डाउट्स हैं वो क्लियर हो जाए। गेटिंग माय
पॉइंट? सब लोग मेरी सुन रहे हो ध्यान से
बात या नहीं सुन रहे बताओ? बिल्कुल ध्यान
से बात सुन रहेगे? तो वहां पर आप क्या
करते हो? क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में आप
तरीका ढूंढते हो कि मुझे उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
के साथ।
ओके? उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के साथ कैसे इंटैक्ट
करना है वो तरीका कुछ भी हो सकता है आप
वनेबिलिटी नहीं है रास्ता नहीं मिल रहा
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में फिर आप ट्राई करोगे
कि मैं कैसे ना कैसे उसके साथ
इंटरेक्ट कर पाऊं इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर
पाऊं और रास्ता ढूंढ पाऊं सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग होगा थर्ड पॉइंट क्या करोगे
वाईफाई देखो हर एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस क्या
करती है कोई ना कोई नेटवर्क की यूज़ करती
है और आजकल हर कोई वाई-फाई का यूज़ करते
हैं। आप क्या करोगे? नोटिस किया आपने
आसपास एरिया को आपने देखा और आपने क्या
देखा कि ओके कंपनी का कोई नेटवर्क ऐसा है
या आप उनके पार्किंग में गए या उनके जो
कैंटीन में जहां पर आपको एक्सेस मिला और
आपको लगा कि आप ओके वाईफाई स्कैनिंग की और
देखा यह वाईफाई यहां तक नेटवर्क कवर करता
है तो डेफिनेटली कंपनी के एम्प्लई तो
उसमें होंगे ही। तो आप क्या कर सकते हो?
वाई-फाई बेस पे अटैक कर सकते हो। वाई-फाई
अटैक्स में वाई-फाई पन टेस्टिंग जिसको
बोलते हैं। क्या कर सकते हो आप? या तो रॉग
वाईफाई रॉग एक्सेस पॉइंट क्रिएट करोगे।
मतलब सेम दिखने वाला हुबू
या फिर उस पासवर्ड को क्रैक करने का उसको
जो पॉसिबल नहीं होगा। तो आप क्या करोगे?
रॉग एक्सेस पॉइंट क्रिएट करोगे। जिससे
क्या होगा कि सेम नेटवर्क पे कोई ना कोई
आपसे जुड़ा तो आपने क्या करना है? बेसिकली
ट्राई करना है कि ओरिजिनल पासवर्ड गेट
करने का। तो एंड आपका मोटो क्या है? उस
कंपनी के नेटवर्क के साथ इंटरेक्ट करना।
तो वहां पर आ गया Wi-Fi
तो और भी क्या चीजें बच गई? एक्सटर्नल
अटैक तो यही है। फिशिंग सोशल इंजन के ये
अंदर आता है। और क्या करोगे आप? और बताओ।
फिजिकल अटैक कर सकते हो। फिजिकल अटैक तो
सोचो आप अब एक बताओ। ये बाहर से नहीं कर
पाए। फिजिकल आ गया। अटैक कर पाए तो वह अलग
बात है या किसी को इन्फ्लुएंस करना किसी
भी एंप्लॉय को वह आपको कोई ना कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन दे दे ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन वो भी
पार्ट है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का
गेटिंग माय पॉइंट
बस समझा नहीं कि अरुण क्या बोल रहे हो आप
कि सर मैं यह बताओ कि अपने बग बाउंट की को
स्टार्टिंग कौन सी वेबसाइट से करूं Google
पे फाइंड करके ट्राई करूं तो पहले मैं एक
चीज बताता हूं आप लोगों को लिए जो भी वेब
एप्लीकेशन पे टेस्टिंग सीख रहे हो या आप
बोलो कि बग बाउंड सीख रहे हो
अटैक से पहले उस चीज को जानो।
उस चीज को पहचानो कि आप उससे क्या करने
चाहते हो। उस चीज के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए ना। सबको सब एक चीज के पीछे पागल
हैं। एसक्यूएल एक्सेस यह सब चीजें आती है।
क्या किसी ने सच में यह जाना है कि
वेबसाइट वर्किंग कैसे काम करती है? काम
कैसे करती है वेबसाइट? क्या यही अटैक हैं?
और यह अटैक हो क्यों रहा है? किसी ने जाना
भी है यह चीज। यह अटैक हो क्यों रहा है?
कि ऐसी क्या कमी है वेबसाइट में जिसके
कारण यह अटैक पॉसिबल है? यह चीज जानो ना।
जब जिस दिन यह चीज आप लोग जान लोगे उस दिन
यू आर द बेस्ट पेंटेस्टर, यू आर द बेस्ट
बग बंटी हंटर। बिकॉज़ आपको पता है कि यह जो
चीज मैं फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं। वह किस वजह से हो सकती है और इस वजह
से नहीं हो सकता। तो इसके कारण और
क्या-क्या चीजें हो सकती है तब आप एक चीज
से दूसरी चीज को लिंक कर पाओगे।
मतलब मैं आपको अगर हिंट दूं तो आपको यह
पता होना चाहिए जब आपने यहां पर यूआरएल
में जो लिंक लिखा फॉर एग्जांपल
डेफोनिक्स.com
रेफरेंस.com लिखा।
यहां लिखने से लेके यहां जैसे ही मैंने
एंटर कर दिया। यहां से लेके सर्वर तक
पहुंचने में सर्वर से रिस्पांस आने में
क्या-क्या हुआ?
क्यों हुआ?
कैसे हुआ?
और इसके बीच में क्या-क्या गलत हो सकता
था?
सब कुछ इसी के बीच में है ना?
वेबसाइट के सारे अटैक इसी बीच में है या
क्या बताओ इससे हटके कोई अटैक है वेबसाइट
का बताओ इससे हटके कोई भी अटैक हो
जिस दिन यह चीज आपको समझ में आ गई
उस दिन आपको किसी भी उसकी चीज की जरूरत
नहीं है अब यह चीज समझ में कैसे आएगी यह
आप लोगों को खुद से काम करना है। उसके लिए
आपको आर्टिकल पढ़ने पड़े पढ़ो बुक पढ़नी
पड़े पढ़ो ट्यूटोरियल देखने पड़े देखो
cos लेने पड़े लो लेकिन
उस कोस्ट की वैल्यू होनी चाहिए। आपको पता
को से कोई वैल्यू मिल रही है। ऐसे नहीं कि
कुछ भी
जो मैं समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं वो
समझो आप।
तो आई होप कि जो मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश
कर रहा था
वह सबको समझ में आ गया होगा कि
एक्चुअल में आपको करना क्या है और मेरा
आपको एक चीज समझ में आया कि मेरा गोल क्या
है
और मैं ऐसे क्यों पढ़ाता हूं बाकी की तरह
मैं क्यों नहीं पढ़ाता कमांड रन की आपको
दिखा दिया बस
जादू
समझ में आ गया? तो हम आपको हिंट दिया कि
आपको करना क्या है लाइफ में? इस लेवल की
नॉलेज गेन करो। उसके बाद यूज़ करो ना यार।
एआई है। सबको यूज़ करो। फिर
सबको यूज़ करो। एक चीज मैं बताता हूं। देखो
रियल लाइफ और साइबर सिक्योरिटी की लाइफ
सेम है।
रियल लाइफ में सोचो कि आपके पास एक घर है
और घर पर आपको लूट करनी है। एग्जांपल भाई
करना मत कोई बाद में सचिन सर ने बोला था
लूट कर ले कर कर लेते हैं। नहीं उसको
कैसे प्लान करोगे आप? सेम वही है कंपनी
ऑर्गेन आपकी वही वही घर है
सेम घर है वही चीज है और वही वही काम करना
है तो जब ऐसे कंपैरिजन करना स्टार्ट कर
दोगे तो यू यू विल डेफिनेटली ग्रो योर
माइंड और आप सोच समझ के सारी चीजें कर
पाओगे
अभिषेक राजपूत नेक्स्ट क्लास में मुझे आप
यह बताना कि पहले एआई क्या है और वेब क्या
है? जिस दिन आपको यह पता चल गया कि एi है
और वेब क्या है? दोनों का अंतर आपको पता
चल गया। यह सवाल आपके दिमाग में नहीं
आएगा। समझ रहे हो कि मैं आपको जो चीज
समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं यह है कि पहले
जानो वो चीज क्या है।
हम उसको टेस्ट क्यों कर रहा हूं? किस
पर्पस से कर रहा हूं। तो टेस्टिंग का आपको
पता चल जाएगा मैं क्या पर्पज कर रहा हूं।
मैं आपको एक चीज बोलूंगा। कभी आपको मौका
मिले। मुझे मौका मिला कोई पेड ट्रेनिंग
लेंगे। ओनली ऑन वेब पेन टेस्टिंग कभी इन
फ्यूचर
मैं लूं या नितेश सर लें
और जो चीजें पर मैंने बताया ना कि ऐसे
सोचो और ऐसे करो
ज्वाइन कर लेना आंख बंद करके
उस दिन मैं जो चीज आपको बताया ना वो चीजें
ऐसे ही क्लियर कर दूंगा या नितेश सर ऐसे
ही कर देंगे हम ऐसे ही करते हैं
हम सेम सोचते हैं सेम हमारे डिसीजन है
बिल्कुल सब कुछ हमारी जो बोलते हैं ना की
फ्रीक्वेंसी मैच होती है हर चीज में।
बिल्कुल अरुण मैंने आपकी चीज पढ़ ली थी।
आप सही कर रहे हो। मैं उनको भी बता रहा
हूं जो बाकी स्टूडेंट्स हैं जिनको सच में
गाइडेंस की जरूरत है। यू आर सही कर रहे हो
आप। तो ऐसे ही करना चाहिए।
तो आज का सेशन मैंने शायद लास्ट के 15
मिनट में काफी पका दिया आप लोगों को। हो
सकता है किसी के लिए इनफेटिव नहीं हो और
हो सकता है किसी के लाइफ में चेंज आए आज
के सेशन के बाद सोचने में हो सकता है कि
अगले दो दिन के लिए चेंज आए भले ही बट कम
से कम सोचे तो कर आई होप
वायरलेस देखेंगे जब मैं पढ़ाऊंगा ना आपको
पता चल जाएगा।
ठीक है? वी विल आल्सो ट्राई कि पढ़ाएंगे
तो फिर डब्ल्यूपीए थ्री भी करेंगे कवर अगर
पढ़ाया तो बट वहां पर प्रॉब्लम यह है कि
लैब कहां से लेके आएंगे। ओके? तो यह चीज
क्लियर होगी कि हम क्या पढ़ने वाले हैं।
इस सेक्शन में क्या एजेंडा है और हमारे
डीएचई का भी क्या एनालॉजी है? डीएचई हम
क्यों पढ़ा रहे हैं? ये चीज भी क्लियर हो
गई होगी। और मेरा माइंडसेट आपको बिल्कुल
क्लियर हो गया होगा। और मैं आपको क्यों
फोर्स करता हूं और मुझे क्यों गुस्सा आता
है? बिकॉज़ यार मुझे भी तो
कि आपको ज्यादा से ज्यादा स्टूडेंट को
पढ़ाना है। मेरा एक ही गोल है कि मैं अपने
इंडिया के सभी स्टूडेंट को जो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी सीखना चाहते हैं। मैं या नितेश
सर सबको एक हाई क्वालिटी की हाई क्वालिटी
कंटेंट हाई क्वालिटी नॉलेज दे पाएं।
बस हमारा मेन यही है एक गोल कि आपको एक
बार हमसे नॉलेज ले ली तो हर जगह आपको
भटकना ना पड़े। एक चीज के लिए आपको 10 जगह
जाकर वह चीज ना सीखनी पड़े जो चीज आपको
सीखनी तो एक ही जगह सीखनी पड़े जिससे आपका
टाइम बचे। आपके पैसे बचे और आप कुछ कर
पाओ। बस यही है।
देखो अरुण पर अरुण
लोगों बाईपास करने में इंटरेस्ट है तो
पहले
क्या-क्या रेस्ट्रिकशंस हो सकते हैं? सो
देखो ग्रो योर माइंड आई एम गिविंग यू हिंट
कि वेबसाइट अलऊ क्या कर रही है?
जो चीज वैलिड है वह अलऊ कर रही है ना
तो उसी का उसी का जरिया अपनाओ उसी को सोचो
कि जो अलऊ कर रही है क्या उसके थ्रू मैं
कुछ पूछ सकता हूं जो मेरे काम का हो समझ
में आ गया कहते हैं कि एक घर मुझे एक किसी
घर को टारगेट करना है एक घर में तो जो मैं
उसको नोटिस कर रहा हूं कि मुझे पता है कि
गार्ड मे मुझे को नहीं जाने देगा
लेकिन मुझे एक चीज नोटिस की किन-किन को
जाने दे रहा है और मुझे जो चाहिए
जो चीज नहीं मिल रही एटलीस्ट अगला स्टेप
बढ़ने के लिए जो जाने दे रहे हैं उनसे मैं
कैसे करवा सकता हूं या कैसे उनको मैं
इन्फ्लुएंस करके या कैसे कर सकता हूं या
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं कि मेरा काम भी चल
जाए और सामने वाले को पता भी ना चले
गेटिंग माय पॉइंट दिस इज अ सेम गेम गेम
विद वेबसाइट
शायद अरुण यह हिंट काफी होगा। आप समझ गए
होंगे मैंने आपको क्या गाइड किया है। जो
चीज अलाउड है ना उस पे रिसर्च करो कि जो
अलाउड है भैया उससे मैं क्या या इतना
अच्छी क्या चीज यूज़ कर सकता हूं जो
मेरी हेल्प करे।
बाकी चीजें हाथ में नहीं है। लेकिन जो चीज
हाथ में है वह कर सकते हो।
बैटिंग माय पॉइंट अरुण।
तो आज को सेशन को एंड करते हैं। काफी हो
गया। बच्चे बोर हो के चले गए मुझे पता है।
और मिलते हैं फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन में अपने
किसको स्टार्ट करते हैं? आज नेक्स्ट सेशन
में वप पेन टेस्टिंग। वप सिक्योरिटी
टेस्टिंग को स्टार्ट करते हैं। एजेंट हम
देख चुके हैं। ओके? तो चलिए फिर बाय-बाय।
टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन
गाइस। जल्दी मिलते हैं इनको एज ए कंटिन्यू
सीरीज रखेंगे हम।
ओके बाय-ब गुड नाइट एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन। जल्दी मिलते हैं। बाय-ब एवरीवन। गुड
नाइट।